[Music]
welcome the fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith I'm marpa noise ah oh [ __ ] welcome
back everybody's been a red-hot minute
business since we've been here at our
home at the scum and villainy Cantina
here in Hollywood on Hollywood Boulevard
put your hands ago those are the folks
listening and watching at home know that
you are real
[Applause]
today is Tuesday is election day
everyone's wearing these [ __ ] Daffy
stickers saying I voted I put up into a
tweet like hey man go out and vote
doesn't matter who you vote for and at
the end of the day they give you a free
[ __ ] sticker and I'm shocked by how
many people were like I didn't get a
[ __ ] sticker that's the bargain right
yeah it must be just a California thing
but most of the people in New Jersey
were like I didn't get a [ __ ] sticker
that sucks
I know I feel bad I mean I guess I give
me exercising with civic duty but I want
a [ __ ] prize I was stuck on duty the
I went to my polling place with the wife
and the kid and the kid can vote now and
stuff so we was her first election I
can't remember I think she voted I think
she voted in the 2016 maybe not she's 19
now so with that know this might been
her first voting Wow
holy [ __ ] we yeah I guess it was a big
deal I was trying to remember did we
take a picture we did take pictures and
[ __ ] for some reason I thought she had
voted before it was all thrown because
[ __ ] when we left the voting place we
were the voting place and you know I was
boating and as I was leaving I saw my
periphery somebody all dressed like in
red white and blue like just very like
loud like we patriotic so when we left I
was driving home and I was like anybody
else see the lady dressed like in the
red white and blue pants and [ __ ]
patriotic much and my wife's like that
was Katy Perry bro
and I was like no it was she's like oh
yeah she had a little dog and people
taking pictures of her that was [ __ ]
Katie Paris I think I thought she was
just dressed interestingly and people
like oh how patriotic and [ __ ] and then
I looked at her Instagram she's right it
was [ __ ] Katy Perry but the all I
took away from that it was like I live
in the same voting district as Katy
Perry were you in the back of that
picture like it's not her who is that
girl I didn't I realized I don't look up
a lot man like like I keep my head down
when I move through a crowd or something
like that because I didn't really like
make block and make eye contact because
he had on a swivel man
I guess that with the frame yeah I just
don't I don't know an honestly I don't
know if I came face to face with her if
I would be like Katy Perry cuz doesn't
she change her hairstyle all the time
she's a chameleon yeah exactly so I
would be forgiven if I was like I didn't
recognize Katy Perry nah man keep your
head on a swivel me I don't know where
they are
[ __ ] going on nothing but she didn't
seem to recognize me either so we're
even
well you'reyou're different than you
were the last time she didn't see you
that's true you've lost like 95 pounds
since the last time she didn't see you
it'd be amazing if I went to her
Instagram she was like I saw Silent Bob
look-alike at their polling station just
wasn't pulling it off the political as
the show gets get D to a pony now with
that out of the way how you been I've
been good man I've been seeing each
other since Vancouver we did this in
Vancouver it was a [ __ ] blast we had
a really good time
yeah I'm still waiting to hear on that
big project thing that I was working on
I heard some positive news today but
we've not heard the news you know what
makes everybody go we is the news that
makes everybody go whoo it's not it's
not the Indecent Proposal news where
you're like on a bed just swimming in
cash yeah no certainly not and not even
close to the moment where I could be
like this is it that's that's what I
kind of most look forward to one way or
another being able to say hey this is
what I've been doing
like the last six months or something
like that so if they decide not to do it
I'll be able to tell the story and be
like but it didn't happen have they
decided to do it then then it'll
somebody else will tell the story for a
little bit yeah so I just I'm for a guy
who you know does a lot of podcasts and
a lot of [ __ ] talking it's very
difficult to have that much content in
my life and not be able to access it or
touch it because if I do if I start
talking about it on podcast I'll [ __ ]
probably lose the whole thing and stuff
and that's a weird position being the
whole thing is a weird position to be in
because I've rarely work for somebody
else anymore I generally just work for
myself and I remember why because when
you work for yourself there's no like
waiting for an answer like you have the
answer you are the answer and you just
kind of go forward so there are benefits
to being in D and there's benefits to
working for other people and stuff like
that but the waiting game is one of
those things where you're like oh man
like I can chart my own future every
other step of the way except if I'm
working for somebody else then it's up
to them right so I look forward to the
moment where I'd you talk about it but I
still don't have any concrete news other
than we took another step forward and it
was crazy positive so we'll see what
happens after that but I can share I was
away for a month working on Supergirl
Vancouver and we finished our episode
went through the post process Barbara's
the editor I've worked with her before
on a couple other episodes she's really
great and and I edit so I was able to
kind of talk editor talk and short speak
and I love bringing the episode down and
stuff and I don't even have to go into
the room to do it and so I just send her
like cut points and then I asked I
double check every time I asked her and
they her assistant when I did Popeye the
editing room I was like does it is it go
sure irritating that I send like
timecode and they're like why why would
that be go sir irritating you know easy
it is just throw it into the [ __ ]
computer and it takes it out like thank
you so I was like alright right on so we
went through that process and I really
liked the episode like it turned out
really well I'm not even saying I did a
good job
there's definitely flourishes that I
feel responsible for but generally the
cast
Kru make this show every week without me
and stuff we just got very lucky and as
much as Eric Carrasco who's been on this
show
he wrote co-wrote the episodes so he
came up with me and stuff and he tends
to keep me honest I'm a very lazy
filmmaker on my own [ __ ] and if when I'm
working on other people's [ __ ] that
doesn't change so at the end of the day
I'll always find the shortest route out
of something and you know most of the
times I'm thinking not about what the
final products could have because I know
it's gonna be wonderful they're
excellent craftspeople I'm always
thinking about the cast and crew and I'm
like how do I get us out of here as
quickly as possible because they lurk
where they usually work long hours and
one of the things that that I when I
come up one of the things they like
about me is the like oh [ __ ] we're gonna
get out of here early every day because
I kind of shoot only what I need I don't
overshoot coverage and stuff and you
know it's I'm one hand one could say hey
you're not given the editor as much
options on the other hand barbara has
never once complained like it's pretty
easy to put together the episodes and I
like to spare people the time sometimes
they have chunky scripts and you wind up
shooting material that's gonna get cut
and as somebody who like lives a life
more of an editor than anything else
it's easy to read the script to be like
this scenes gonna not be in the final
this is probably going to go away
so in production like I'll make the case
feel like hey can we lose this scene
because like right now we're running
real long with 60 minutes we're gonna
have to get down to 42 like I feel like
we can add this line to this scene and
like we can get rid of this two pages
right here and then it's up to the
producers and Jess and Robert this time
like let us get rid of a scene which
saves the cast and crew of having to go
through shooting something which never
gets used anyway that seems like a kind
of futile ex futile exercise so because
of that I'm always thinking about how he
goes out of here early and stuff
thankfully Eric's there to be like you
know don't forget there are three H's on
this show
there's heart and humor and I'd like
that's I'm there for that a hundred
percent but then he's like the Third Age
is heroics that's the spectacle and
that's where I always kind of like I'm
not used to doing spectacle so I'm
always like Matt's
we also do that or whatever [ __ ] so
Erica be like no we need this you should
get this so because of that team effort
Bob the ad Bob Crippen was [ __ ]
amazing I worked at them on flash he's
recently joined Supergirl dudes of
[ __ ] ace has forgotten more about
directing than Oliver no and stuff it's
one beautiful shot of Kyler in the in
the episode coming up or you know she's
leaving the room and somebody says wait
you know and there's a kind of like flip
at the end of the scene and so you know
I was like I will come over here and
then when he says wait we'll be pushing
on her and she'll turn around and stuff
very you know is maybe two extra shots
and Bob comes over and he's just like
just ever come to the door and walk into
the shot and he'll say wait and she'll
stop right in the camera and she can
give a great reaction shot and I was
like thank you I want to watch your show
and so we go shoot that man he's the
[ __ ] wonderful because of that we got
a really cool episode I felt pretty good
about it [ __ ] there's something that
happens in the fifth act which is always
the action act which is I've never seen
them do on the show before so I'd like
it it's really kind of like oh [ __ ] this
is cool so I felt pretty good about the
episode and there are three masters that
you serve when you make one of these
shows three levels you've got to go
three big bosses stage right the
producers the first people you have to
make happy second is the studio and then
third is the network so throughout the
process the idea the ideal is you get
them all without having to change
anything and you know that's rare
because there's usually somebody with an
opinion somewhere going like I don't
know about this line or whatever to find
but they just told me that we hit the
[ __ ] hat-trick yeah yeah the
producers were like love this episode
and the studio was like love this
episode and the network was like we
loved this episode so I felt like really
smart for a second well
like I spent so much time going like I'm
not good at this job and then I felt
like oh yeah and like and then I
remembered I didn't do it a bunch of
people we all did it together and [ __ ]
but they liked something I did in as
much as there's a tone that episode is
it's tough to say scary but there's some
[ __ ] like frightening elements and it
and stuff plays with the dreams a bit so
we do some fucked-up [ __ ] and I just
borrowed from movies I've seen my whole
life like we will do little Jacob's
Ladder here and we'll borrow from a
little home in here and stuff so we
built this kind of sequence where it is
kind of a little bit horrific but the
rest of the episode is also like fun and
light because I tend to come in and
lighten stuff up so totally the episode
is kind of in this wonderful place of up
down up down doesn't play like any of
the other episodes I've seen in recent
seasons so it feels like something kind
of fresh and it's nice to know that
they're all like yay because it means I
might get invited back one day to do
another so it wasn't like you know I've
been gone for a month but at least it
was for a good effort
I did some [ __ ] yeah 4:08 it's coming up
and I think four episodes they got an
episode coming up I think I don't know
if it aired last night but it was a big
403 where they do the backstory of their
one of their big bads this season as a
character called agent Liberty and he's
kind of fairly like racist against
aliens they're doing this kind of
allegory and he's very anti alien
metaphors as science fiction so so he
they did a whole episode that dove into
his origin and showed him go from like a
normal guy to like how he became an
extremist which was it's it's incredible
I saw it early because I watched the
first four episodes when I got there I
was like what have you shot so far what
can i watch they gave me four episodes
and that one I thought was absolutely
[ __ ] incredible sam witwer plays the
character agent Liberty Ben Lockwood
who's a secret identity and he's
wonderful he's a Star Wars guy big in
the Star Wars guy and a Battlestar guy
as well Crashdown yes yes [ __ ] well
done but he's
big into Star Wars you know me I'm
[ __ ] like I love Star Wars and [ __ ]
like that and when we were chit-chatting
on set like you know I was like hey man
I know you've done voices and [ __ ] like
that like [ __ ] it is Darth Maul just
like just seeing you know Solo a month
or two before and he's the voice of
Darth Maul and he was in the cartoons as
Darth Maul so we were chit-chatting Star
Wars and he whipped out his [ __ ] Star
Wars dick or lightsaber and it was way
bigger than mine like I've always felt
like I was a fan and [ __ ] but he drops
him like deep cuts [ __ ] Star Wars
[ __ ] that I didn't know and I was
sitting there like a blue milk like I
was [ __ ] really outgunned and [ __ ]
like that he's clever so a very smart
and and big star Wars fan but he plays
agent liveries fantastic in that episode
if you get a chance to see it the
episodes entitled Man of Steel but it's
a secret origin episode that I've never
seen before is really well done and they
explain why he is a space racist bassist
yeah and it's spaces yes and it works
it's not like you know you don't go oh I
forgive them but at least you're like oh
I see how this started man is there a
caravan let's leave the politics outside
[Laughter]
a Dodge Caravan alright man so that's
all I've been doing recently I went I've
seen some movies and watch some TV shows
man I've been swallowing up the content
you have been you've been consuming I
have been you'd be creating I've been
consuming what I saw what did I see I
didn't see recently I saw a movie that
isn't out yet or it's about to be out
maybe it comes out today Jason Reitman
front runner
oh yeah the movie about gary hart and
one to see it the other night
wonderful insanely well acted [ __ ] jason
reitman all he makes are like Oscar
movies like every time he goes up to bat
he's never like let's make a dick and
fart joke movie like it's it's always
like hope [ __ ] there's gonna be up for
Oscars and stuff insanely well done that
was the last movie I saw though but it
was
weird sitting through a movie that
wasn't a comic book movie even likewhat
had Wolverine in it where's he gonna
kill people yeah like pop your [ __ ]
claws Gary Hart that'll show him but it
was it was good watch man it's
definitely worth seeing when it comes
out what have you seen them I saw venom
right on that I haven't seen you I don't
know if right on is the right pair of
words for venom what is your it made a
bunch of money you made a [ __ ] ton of
money I think you so you can't hurt it
now no no there's nothing I can do to
venom besides tell the truth about that
like I never understood why you're
making venom movie aside from the fact
that people seem to have a relation to
that character even though it's not
really character it's a [ __ ] alien
symbiotic suit that needs spider-man and
Peter Parker to be a thing that works
anyway and so you're making a movie
about Eddie Brock who's an [ __ ] and
it's always an [ __ ] like just dick
move after dick move out - dick move
like its aim should be Eddie dick move
Brock for the entire movie because he's
just an [ __ ] and so I'm supposed to
care that this [ __ ] life is ruined
by a suit that calls itself venom alien
and it's goo why does it have language
that's our like just none of it made any
sense I will say though that Tom Hardy
is in 9 different movies at the same
time and all of them are kind of
interesting just none of them were venom
you know like those scenes where I'm
super hungry he climbs it off like he
does it like a Bruce Wayne and climbs in
a pool and so it's like biting lobsters
like daryl hannah from [ __ ] splash
because those are the two movies it
wants to be and that 5 minute sequence
and we would be splash and dark bang go
alright what do we do now I know he's
gonna be a dude like fighting guys in
the apartment it's gonna be a little
like take him except there's no kid or
any emotional content what now
motorcycle chase what
sure it's like every scene somebody had
a different idea that did not have to
connect to the scene before like it's a
big giant cinematic game of telephone so
by the end of the movie none are the
tracks to what the beginning of the
movie was it's just [ __ ] happening all
the time what is there sure I have spoil
a bunch of [ __ ] okay because if you
haven't seen it yet you're never gonna
see I spoilers I've not I've not read
anywhere on the internet that there's
that spider-man shows up is there any
spider-man related material no matter
what it's in [ __ ] San Francisco they
couldn't even do Queens or New York or
anywhere where spider-man might possibly
be there no that's crazy yeah he's like
a shitty vice journalist at the
beginning like the kind of douchebag you
don't want to watch on the Internet
there's like I may be broke let me tell
you the [ __ ] truth because the accent
kind of comes and goes every now and
again and pasta like what are you what
are you doing here man and then super
spoiler the the credits tag is Eddie
Brock you know now in sort of control of
his symbiote who decides he wants to
stay on earth for reasons that you never
manifest themselves in real actionable
ways I got my next big story who is it
gonna be
I don't know I'm gonna go in this prison
and like the Harley Quinn cell they have
here which is just like you know the
square box surrounded by a bunch of
guards with Hannibal Lecter him they
elected him and and it's a Woody
Harrelson and a shitty red wig who's
like when I get out of here it's gonna
be carnage and we're like so but that
right there I'd be like oh [ __ ] I'm
going to bed him too
[Music]
that's not against you man they saved it
for that you said they're gone [ __ ] this
[ __ ] this [ __ ] this and then they're
like next movies carnage Alecto my
[ __ ] money right now I haven't seen
it yet but I imagine I will my kids saw
it and she was on the other page she was
like oh I loved it that was it really
he said yeah it's really funny he's
weird somebody's did clearly made like
300 million dollars worldwide crazy
amount of money looks like there'll be
another venom venom - this is like a
movie now that it's proven itself maybe
Sony's like alright you can mention
spider-man it's the first one of those
that it said in association with Marvel
not Marvel yeah in association with
light we acknowledge it exists from Sony
from Marvel adjacent Sony yes like
looking for Kevin froggies name in the
credits and you'll not see it anywhere
and it's a movie with a bunch of really
talented actors getting paid like why is
Michelle Williams in this she's got an
Oscar I gotta get paid as I met Anita
she's really amazing no funny gotta get
paid
she venoms out at one point spoilers
yeah for no good reason
does it look cool no no no the CG is
like oddly spotty where like sometimes
it's really cool and interesting but
there's this big fight at the end which
I am never a fan of like CG punching CG
in the face and I'm supposed to give a
[ __ ] but but they do this thing where of
course like Eddie Brock is in venom and
and Riz Ahmed character is inside riot
because again that's a name and alien
gives itself sure and so they're
fighting and then like it gets so heated
that they like punched the humans out of
the symbiotic suits so this is weird
like body horror where you can see the
humans inside and teeth and muscles and
sinew and it's kind of cool and then
there's other times it feels like a
nine-year-old got a hold of a laptop
like this is what I mean sure how does
it look when his hands become giant axes
like [ __ ] really it just had to look
better than the old Nintendo game that
was all I was mean marginally progress
yes I saw an on comic book movie with my
mom while I was in Florida I went to
visit my mother I saw a star is born
did you yeah I kind of saw it because my
eyes were soaking wet the whole pocket
oh my god it was really sweet if you're
if you're somebody who fancies yourself
like an artist are creative like it hits
you on a bunch of different levels and
stuff if you're somebody who's known
somebody with an addiction problem
it hits you on a bunch of [ __ ] levels
if you're somebody who was like [ __ ] man
Bradley Cooper's the most talented
person in the world
it hits you on a bunch of buggin levels
like you know you sit there going like
nobody should be able to [ __ ] pull
off that raccoon in this movie you know
what I'm saying
it's unfair you should only be good at
one [ __ ] thing I bet just dick is
huge too much like this yeah oh he stole
us amulets poison anybody seminal into
the movie movie was really well made
movie like from you know just a guy who
watches movies standpoint and a guy who
fancies himself a filmmaker standpoint
really well done yet another argument
for like an actor and actress who sits
behind a bunch of different directors
over 10 20 years will aggregate into a
wonderful filmmaker themselves you learn
what to do what not to do develop your
own style it's a really great flick man
I enjoyed the [ __ ] you know Hollywood
movie everything happens [ __ ] fast
like he meets her and then 10 minutes
later she's worldwide famous and [ __ ] so
you know it's definitely fantasy but but
they do something I don't know if I
could talk about it it's maybe too soon
and it spoils a bunch of [ __ ] but they
do something in the third act which I
found like oh I wish they had done it
more like they did it in the Barbra
Streisand movie but then it was more
realistic the way they did it when they
play pattycake
yeah no code yes no the other thing
it involves is character and stuff it's
pretty pretty gripping stuff but like
emotional as [ __ ] like just a crazy my
kid told me before I went because I was
trying to get my wife to go with me and
she's like I am watching that [ __ ]
she's a real loving woman and but my kid
she had already seen it and she's like
dad I love you but I can't go back it
was such a motional turmoil I can't do
it to myself so I asked mom when I was
down there you want to go and she was
like I took you to see the one with
Barbra Streisand in 1976 and I was like
I remember I was like can't we [ __ ]
go see like Benjy again please why are
we seeing this but it was really great
man she was wonderful I've heard nothing
but good things about her totally great
she I'm not familiar with her other than
like she's [ __ ] huge and stuff but
the two things that I am familiar with
her like her Saturday Night Live
appearances like and and this and I
thought she was great in both from
really charming he's fantastic though
they should give him all the [ __ ]
awards man for acting - seems like a
nice guy I went online and like an idiot
I tweeted a thing saying I have to think
that somewhere Madonna is looking at
Lady Gaga in stars born thinking of this
should be the life that I have right now
because Madonna has hungered so
desperately for cinematic glory and Lady
Gaga's getting him an Oscar nomination
for this and there's a decent chance she
could win and you know that Madonna's
like that [ __ ] stole all of my [ __ ]
moves that [ __ ] is like me dresses and
[ __ ] I was doing that shouldn't 80s like
I was the image queen man I'd I did a
[ __ ] sex book I did all that [ __ ] and
I put in my [ __ ] time in and I get a
Vita as good as I get
[ __ ] you Hollywood like I want to just
like in her like [ __ ] rage cave just
looking at it like working a British
accent to death and just like I think
you're getting upset on a rehab dude I
mean knowing what I'm hearing is your
deep Madonna for him
converging like every [ __ ] was
in 1987 I bought the Pepsi cuz yeah but
I and I incurred the wrath of a Madonna
hoard that I didn't know existed
rightfully so man why poke your nose in
Madonna's business and be like you know
what I think carefully it was a rough
day
when I had like Gaga fans like you're
right in Madonna fan say die [ __ ]
dead man on Batman I saw a different
music movie
well one Bohemian Rhapsody oh yeah all
the money this way and all the money and
I if you remember and our San Diego show
I went long and hard and how excited I
was that there would be a queen movie
yes wait it's a queen Bohemian Rhapsody
or venom I will say that Bohemian
Rhapsody has better songs but put that
[ __ ] on a poster Bohemian Rhapsody it is
it is not a great movie it uh it's it's
it's montage for too much of it it's one
of those like hey it's Freddie Mercury
he's got an amazing voice u-joints queen
queens amazing something they're rock
stars
we need this to enter rich and famous
contract here's your [ __ ] evade its
contract we're touring Japan
we're going everywhere are you sure you
didn't see a star is born cuz that's
exactly the [ __ ] X you know it's like
Freddy he says he got married once
remember that turns out bisexual no
you're gay I'm bisexual gay gay gay okay
and then we're famous we're still famous
and then I iced elated all my friends
and what's going on drinking too much
kind of someone Bowie maybe I don't know
oh [ __ ] I got this disease that seems to
be infected in the gay community I need
to tell people about it but not yet cuz
I want to keep it a secret
and oh hey man you want to go play live
aid I don't know I would say in a while
I'm spoiling most
by the way Bohemian Rhapsody is one
minute my bark retardant ladies and
gentlemen give it up for him he's almost
done almost done take us home zigzoo we
gotta do this one concert what's the
concerts gonna be [ __ ] live eight man
bout Geldof what's he doing he's
gathering every [ __ ] rock show in the
world a billion people watch this
concert well Queens never playing from
how many people before but we should
before we go can you look at yourself in
the mirror and say we didn't play live a
because we were afraid Freddie couldn't
sing what they do live a twenty five
minutes he lets movies just Live Aid
literally they recreate the entire Live
Aid concert and it's awesome because
it's Live Aid right and it's Queen and
every time they're singing every time
Ronny Malick is doing his thing every
time the band that's cast because they
look exactly like the band that was
queen like pretends to be playing
instruments it's awesome
once they charge the end of this movie
with with aids and with legacy and with
like can he do it one last time it's
amazing
but everything before that last forty
minutes is like you watched a bad
documentary about Queen hmm also further
spoiler Mike Myers is in this movie Mike
Myers plays a record executive the guy
who decided to like on a whim say all
right [ __ ] it I guess you guys can do
Bohemian Rhapsody and then they cut
Bohemian Rhapsody this like sort of
pretty cool sequence about how you make
us all in that [ __ ] Daffy and then
the band brings it back into this record
executive and Mike Myers sits there
behind a desk as the camera pushes him
slowly and says do you really think that
kids in there cos are gonna be banging
their heads to this [ __ ] song and I
just like like a slow tear as I realize
that this entire [ __ ] sequence is
built up to Mike Myers doing a Wayne's
World joke Wow and that's when I was
like [ __ ] you movie
you didn't [ __ ] airing that at all
but it's better than venom because it
has better songs müber reviews by Martha
Martha give it up for me I watched I
watched some television I am almost done
with daredevil season 3 oh [ __ ] they
survived the snap
Santos [ __ ] snapped and half the
Marvel Netflix characters went away
[ __ ] it there ain't many left man like
Luke hey Danny yoga fist are you there
yeah and it's it's surprisingly good
because I did not love the second season
of daredevil because the second season a
daredevil managed to make ninjas boring
a thing I never thought possible before
like how do you [ __ ] make ninjas a
thing I don't want to watch daredevil
season 2 object lesson number 1 I
remember the end though like when he's
like [ __ ] marching across the roof
spoilers and he's all those ninjas like
we're about to take him down and [ __ ]
looks like a Frank Miller comic book for
a frame and then awesome they get shot
one by one you look up the punter she's
like go get him red you can't protect a
brat yeah it wasn't strong but it wasn't
strong a season 1 this I interviewed the
cast and the Ken the showrunner for this
season at New York Comic Con while I was
gone while I was doing a Supergirl I
went over in New York and interviewed
folks for the IMDB and the show creator
I was like this trailer looks [ __ ]
phenomenal man it looks like it might
correct me if I'm wrong are you doing
born again he goes we do a little born
again he goes we do a little guardian
devil and I was like he's like I know
that's why I said that [ __ ] I'm gonna
suck a dick just a little bit right now
oh [ __ ] it felt cool man to be one of
those Marvel artists that people take
their [ __ ] and make it better she would
make money off it
no and there's there's a really great
sequence it's a prison escape that is
one of those long one of those just one
take jammies that's like ten minutes
long and it's just all Charlie Cox just
barely surviving oh really well done
really I look forward to that ya know
it's only worth it
so what episode of you run I am on
episode 12 of 13 oh [ __ ]
and again it could have been 10 really
they even all have been 10 yeah I think
there's you know that bit when a
character says here's my batch trauma
and it's affected me forever campaign is
like my brother died and I was
responsible for it and I never had a I
never got back in the same page with my
parents and I've always been carrying
this wound with me you don't really want
to see that there's an entire episode
where you see that oh really and it's
like it's never gonna be as good as it
is when she talks about it to see it you
know I did there's I have a quote up on
my on my wall at work that I that I put
up when I was in Castle Rock where I was
way more appropriate to Stephen King
quote that says every character has a
backstory none of it is interesting like
it's kind of true like backstory unless
it's front story back story just informs
of things you see in the president you
don't actually need to make it present
you just need to like alright what
happened well there was a [ __ ] clone
war and we did a bunch of [ __ ] do I need
to see the clone wars not really because
it's not gonna be as cool as it is when
obi-wan talks about it because you get
to see it land on him you get this and
you get to do most of that work
imagining what it is and once you make
that subtext once you make that it feel
it takes text it's never quite as cool
as you want it to be cuz backstory just
need that interesting smart I mean
you're breaking [ __ ] hearts the world
over for people who are like all I do is
write the backstory on these things
20 years I've been raining [ __ ] Star
Wars Clone Wars [ __ ] sorry what is the
what is the other thing you watched I
gave up on The Walking Dead about five
years ago I want to say I tuned in for
the negan like introduction and began
episode I just want to see what the show
is [ __ ] going on and that's and we
talked about it the idea that this show
is just going to be brutal and it will
end brutal and there is no hope for
anybody and how is that entertaining
right the slow sad descent into just the
abyss but I watched the last Sunday
night the the last Andrew Lincoln
episode that's it for for Rick Grimes
you would think it did you did you watch
it I didn't I'm no longer an AMC
employee I don't have to watch it about
shake up my shows like thank you
gentlemen I'm done with the Walking Dead
after you killed off Karl go [ __ ]
yourselves know that and it's it's kind
of a lovely episode because it's it it
works perfectly well if you haven't seen
the show in a long time like for me and
it opens with Rick kind of impaled on
the cinder block and there's a giant
horde of zombies kind of approaching and
he's gonna wake up Chloe self back on
his horse and make his way back to the
camp and every time he's and massive
loss of blood leading the entire time he
can't make the horse gallop because that
would just kill him ultimately it was a
sort of slow escape from this
encroaching thing and every time he
passes out he like flashes back or
hallucinates to another point in his
life when somebody that he loved died
hmm and died either had his handler
because of his actions did they do Lori
his wife they didn't do Lori cuz maybe
they couldn't get it but they did they
did Shane so it flash they could get him
got him she's [ __ ] busy all the time
there's this really nice scene in a car
where like you still can't protect Rick
didn't stop saying that I didn't protect
her I know and so that's a kind of
lovely scene there's another scene with
Hershel like and I think the last thing
that he shot before he passed away
oh god that's right he passed
and so I guess it's another lovely thing
where it's basically absolving Rick of
his sins that like you see me cousin
green is in when they're seen it's and
it's look really haunting it's it's a
sea of corpses and some of which I think
you see like Lori's face there you see
Karl's hat you see a bunch of [ __ ] and
so it's this wonderful sort of eulogy
for this character and he makes this
choice at the end of it which you've you
haven't see I'm not gonna spoil but it
should be the perfect send-off for a
character like this you have sold me I'm
gonna watch this episode and then the
news broke wait a second I might have
just saved myself a dollar 99 on iTunes
I possible the news broke that AMC is
making three standalone Rick Grimes
movies yes so you don't even have to
spoil what happened at the end of that
episode he doesn't die let me tell you
this I hope those Rick Grimes stories
ain't backstory it'll really piss off
Stephen King they are not because at the
end of the episode like it's the oh [ __ ]
he blew himself up in that great he
sacrifice himself for the family
good move Rick and then like four miles
away on a riverbank somewhere
Rick rolls up I'm still alive you got
rickrolled you got Rick rolling
literally we're gonna give you gonna
make three movies so are they AMC like
movie of the week or they television
movies they haven't talked about whether
they'll be in theaters or not but
they're saying that they're gonna make
him on like future film budgets I would
I mean you know makes sense to do it for
the network I don't know if I would take
the risk on theatrical run yeah seems
like their audiences can Contracting no
Kevin the numbers a little bit
they dropped by 50% this is yeah I hope
that doesn't come off as Cadi
[Applause]
they were always good as I teased James
he was always very good just kept that
show on comic book man far longer than
it needed to be but you sold me on that
show I'm actually gonna watch that up
like exactly it's a really well-done
episode it doesn't directly do you know
did he do it yeah okay and that's one of
my favorite aspects came out of the
whole Walking Dead thing man then he
became like legit director this is one
of the part of the can be effects group
with Bob Kurtzman who I've worked with a
lot three kids who did special effects
he's big jaws fan he's like one awesome
[ __ ] and he a grenade from a guy who
like did effects and blood and [ __ ] like
that on Walking Dead to like one of
their best directors that they have
really cool story man shows you that
talent outs he's one of those cats his
whole life when he was a kid people
waste your time with this [ __ ]
monster [ __ ] for that's why man it's
like it's not a waste of time if you
could put it to use for you later on in
life and [ __ ] when I was a kid they
would be like what you [ __ ] waste
your time with a movie [ __ ] for man
caring about movies well thank God yeah
cuz that's all I did with my life is
care about movies I don't care about you
just care about movies
[ __ ] you misses her look what I did yeah
so [ __ ] you dad no he was the guy that
if I could put movies in my head like he
was the one that fostered the whole
thing he like he hated his job he'd love
to escape so he liked going to the
movies he passed that on to me because I
didn't do sports I was heavy and [ __ ]
he's like movies are good for him he
doesn't have to catch anything alright
we've done with our Prix we don't with
our Prix we're done chit-chatting folks
we're just about ready to start the show
man this show is comprised of two
sections but tonight everything's gonna
be different cuz we got some special
things going on but what is gonna remain
the same of course mr. mark barnard and
he comes from the world of news he
worked at the LA Times as an editor he
worked at The Hollywood Reporter as an
editor he worked at playboy as
editor oh my god man he was a he knows
news of anyone knows news he's got a
nose for news mark barnard went to the
internet downloaded news for us tonight
give it up for Mark Bernard man he's
gonna give me the news I'm just saying
my copy/paste fingers like they got a
workout this week there's been a lot of
news since the last time we cover at all
I guess at the top we can talk about the
[ __ ] fan oh snap on the marvel
universe on TV which is iron fist and
Luke Cage both went away
iron fist got iron fisted man just gone
[ __ ] gone and this was after a second
season that people were like hey it's
better it's taken a job this seems to
have more to do with the cost of the
shows and Disney's impending dtc app
direct-to-consumer app whatever the
Disney Netflix the Netflix killer that
they're brewing that seems to be the
channel that we all want I mean this
probably touches into other news but
they announced that they're doing vision
and the Scarlet Witch shows and now
they've announced that they're doing
Falcon and the Winter Soldier shows on
par with the studio budgets Kevin Feige
producing yep same case with the same
[ __ ] cast like they're they're really
going for it so in that world like
having Marvel product on Netflix doesn't
really make sense anymore they're about
to be competitors yeah so and they were
expensive shows like New York will give
you some tax credits but not that much
and they spent a boatload of money and
the ratings began to erode because when
they were new like Luke Cage crash
Netflix like and remember they said too
about Iron Fist they're like I broke all
sorts of records that we were like tell
us the records like we're not gonna put
it broke but there's a show between 48
and 49 years old at 2 o'clock in the
morning in Pittsburgh they did find a
very thin demographic for it to rule by
but yeah I guess it was diminishing
Reach
I think so I mean they haven't announced
anything about Punisher which they've
shot already there's a there's a second
season already in the can there's a
third season of Jessica Jones in the can
and we just saw season 3 of daredevil
and so there's no word yet I mean if
those will continue to go on or not
because those feel like those are the
ones that have the most story legs I
suppose but they announced no defenders
a while back and with those two
cancellations and I don't see a world in
which Heroes for Hire ends up on the
Disney app a lot of people said that
they're like well now that he lost his
show on his show why don't they get
together and do like they did in the
comics do Heroes for Hire but yeah that
would look like at this point it would
have to be the Disney app channel doing
it right and it sounds like they're like
ah we're doing Falcon in the Winter
Soldier over here yes I'm see that we're
doing a Loki miniseries with [ __ ]
Hiddleston we don't really need Heroes
for Hire we're good like come on man one
more season of Danny Rand Danny ran yeah
and it's the landscape is changing crazy
just think about is only what three four
years ago that they started these Marvel
shows on Netflix and we're like oh my
god we're in the future and now that
shit's the past they've they've gotten
rid of Dan's hate to be that guy but
we're in a post infinity war climate
what else you got Ewan McGregor is going
to star us black mask in the birds of
prey movie from Christopher Robin -
black mask
this guy's got range man Danny Renton -
Christopher yeah really
in my ass mark put it in my [ __ ] ass
who got doing lines from Christopher
Robin man don't spoil it for these
people Chris - Robin now on home video
what heroin stuff is a bonus feature
where is he playing black mask in the
birds of prey movie and they're calling
it birds of prey yep so this is the
movie that features mostly female cast
which I understand is now going to be
r-rated as well yes it is
yeah Margot Robbie is back a child
Quinn mary elizabeth winstead is
Huntress oh she got the role she got the
role good Smollett Bell is Black Canary
right it was reported there good for her
Rosie Perez is playing Renee Montoya
wait what Rosie Perez is playing Renee
Montoya good for her man I'm trying my
best to channel my [ __ ] Mookie voice
come on Mookie why don't you come by my
house Mookie you didn't do a good job
you know it man cuz I got [ __ ] quince
in my head for white men can't jump
foods that begin with Q for 200 Alex
wow man she was good mark that was very
close it took me a little bit but I was
a Rosie Rosie so she's in the movie as
well this is a movie gonna be directed
by a woman as well I'd imagine yeah
woman named blah blah blah blah blah
hold hold hold
Kathy Yan okay and the storyline is this
is all the Gotham people but no Batman
yes it's like venom or Treadstone or CH
you know that thing you like yeah we're
gonna leave that to the side you know
they're gonna reference him I guarantee
you he makes an appearance if not on you
know maybe on a rooftop [ __ ] the cave
just the [ __ ] bat signals gonna be up
there's no way you can't it's like doing
you know [ __ ] the Lincoln story
without Lincoln for Christ's sakes man
like you got to have him pop up
somewhere all these people do what they
do because he does what he does correct
go through that the huntress inspired by
him mm-hmm Harley Quinn subscribe
brother Joker inspired by him Black
Canary
maybe her she's not really on the list
he's like [ __ ] Bruce Wayne I got nothing
to do with this Polly Queens my [ __ ]
billionaire who else is on that list
I'll tell ya she's a cop like in well we
don't know she's gonna be the question
no I don't know but she was a GCPD
detective
that's Gotham City right I'm sure that
qualifies yeah you got a hope he'll be
Selby felt ill be talked about I think
just Sandra Kane may be innocent haven't
cast her yet I bet you they'll keep it
way quiet and slip in a cameo right like
they will have Batman in it even if it's
not who winds up being the Batman in
Matt Reeves movie even if it's not
Affleck they'll you know if you're doing
this movie as a one-off they're no
longer interested in building a universe
they're just doing movies you could get
away with doing a Batman if it's not Val
Kilmer I'll be very upset gentlemen
bringing him back for the cape and cowl
you loved him in Tombstone the one the
only Val Kilmer he's amazing and Kiss
Kiss Bang Bang it's right and I think he
lost some weight because he had been
ballooning a little bit but he's in Top
Gun - and is he in Top Gun - yeah I
remember he was he was like lobbying for
it at one point he's like I really want
to be in it oh I'm glad good for him
he lost his voice oh he's got one -
gravelly voice so now he's Batman
perfect I'm training for Batman he's
still lost in my grief but he'll be in
that movie for sure yeah I guess they'll
work in the gravelly voice thing hmm
right on man good for him that makes me
happy here and he's in that movie
Anthony Edwards the only one going man I
wish I was in that movie
but I guess they could do them in
flashbacks what if this was like the
goose story Wow
that's it it's gooses son is in the
movie yeah yeah I think so what's his
name plays him well uh what's his name
the guy who was in Fantastic Four played
Reed Richards Oh miles teller he plays I
hope you guys - what leg is dad yeah
it's like it's the goose revenge just
say every goose in a cockpit man it's
like [ __ ] it goes again I could see the
magic you bring to Treadstone hell yeah
let's kill all the [ __ ] characters
off hey do you remember seeing gladiator
in the movies with Russell Crowe when he
is that amazing gladiator Maximus
Decimus Meridius you killed my husband
who literally arrives to gladdy
I know I got you it won't make a sequel
to that movie
oh that's timely yeah took a minute it
took a minute maybe they ought to crack
me how we make a sequel to the movie
where your main character dies and
nobody gives a [ __ ] about anybody else
in the movie wait that's right he dies
yeah so it won't be Russell Crowe no
it'll be a different gladiator it's
supposed to follow remember that little
[ __ ] bratty kid Lucius yeah him he
grew up to be the rock Jason Momoa that
makes sense there I'm in time back they
got me man
yeah Michael B Jordan I'm there this
sounds like they're creating [ __ ]
gladiator and I'm all for it
MA and jaemin hunters character didn't
die so I think they'll bring him back
also cuz he's not dead so maybe he'll be
the connective tissue but and did
Joaquin die at the end of that mm-hm
yeah [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] that prick but yet
Ridley Scott apparently wants to do it
Wow Ridley Scott is trying to shuffle as
many movies least I could do is anything
he [ __ ] wants the guy's like old he's
in his 70s late 70s and he shows no sign
of [ __ ] tiring he still makes legit
wonderful [ __ ] films that movie that
they recast with Kevin Spacey and [ __ ]
on what
with all the all the money in the world
it's great [ __ ] flick like the only
movie of his recently that I didn't
really I wasn't in for was the aliens
know what was the Promethean from
easiest holy [ __ ] man that was job that
was really tough to live like I was
rooting for him especially cuz they
showed The Navigators I was like oh [ __ ]
I'm gonna love this movie
based on the trailer they always [ __ ]
lie and then I was in the theater and I
was like they [ __ ] lied again every
story has a backstory reals none of it
is good that's true they should have
King that [ __ ] but but yeah generally
speaking he makes wonderful stuff so
I'll [ __ ] watch a gladiator sequel
from him they are they have officially
decided to make one of the Game of
Thrones prequels who's making it HBO
alright that makes sense yeah Jane
Goldman who wrote co-wrote both of the
the Kingsmen movies she did all of Mark
Millar's movies okay
she's the showrunner george RR martin is
collaborating with her Weiss and David
Benioff have nothing to do with these
prequels so they're moving on they're
moving at the Star Wars shows Naomi
Watts is going to be the lead of the
next Game of Thrones series that takes
place 8,000 years before
are you serious it takes place a
thousand years before yes
no but none of these people read that
Stephen King quote that's for sure no
not even close why not go forward and
tell the story that way everything we it
seems like if you're doing the backstory
we know what happens in the future and
that kind of ruins it a little bit so if
you did a series that went from the
events of those books forward created
some new [ __ ] you can build on what was
there and reference hey remember all the
characters we like that are too
expensive for the show and stuff like
that is hoping that by setting it so far
in the in the distant previous you're
not expecting it to connect with the
other stuff per se you're not expecting
the like oh [ __ ] that's Daenerys is
great-great-great
great-great-great-great
great-great-great-great grandfather the
only connective tissue will be the White
Walkers presumably presumably it's sort
of according according to this pretzel
wall I betcha this is where the wall
gets built right it chronicles the old
wall wall in this instance I fully
[ __ ] support it man I've seen what
happens on the other side they're pretty
crimson those white lagers it chronicles
the world's descent from the Golden Age
of Heroes into its darkest hour and only
one thing is for sure from the
horrifying secrets of Westeros is
history to the Georgian of the White
Walkers the mysteries of the east to the
Starks of legend it's not the story we
think we know I'll be honest with you
man I wasn't like on board for Game of
Thrones when it began it wasn't until
Jason Mewes is like you got to watch
this [ __ ] they show so much dick on it
was this selling point and made me try
it for some reason I was just like
sounds good and I started watching it so
I love more than I've sold and and I'm
not pretty sold here but I'm sure
they'll get me by making a classy series
Naomi watches what gets me is that what
brings you in yeah I like the John I
love her she's wonderful but the george
RR martin being involved seems like a
good sign
but those Benioff and Weiss man they
seem to have the magic you know I mean I
know they were using this source
material but not having them involved
that's the that's a hurdle yeah you
don't think they'll even bring them back
as producers or nothing like that
apparently they will have no involvement
whatsoever there it is sounds like
everyone got along very well [ __ ] you go
home all right what do you got next they
are making another Flash Gordon movie
[ __ ] a I mean that makes sense it does
make sense although nothing will ever
top the first Flash Gordon movie sure
had Queen songs in it all right if they
bring the Queen
all I gotta do is bring those songs back
but yeah that that's a concept that
could easily be redone why not
the guy who made overlord which I
haven't seen yet as the new JJ from JJ's
movie they'd like world war 2 zombie
thing guys parachuting into behind enemy
lines and there are zombies or something
vampires or some pyres opens Friday
opens this Friday what is it Overlord
the Lord got him Julie's Avery he's
taking a swing at Flash Gordon so this
guy is gonna direct Flash Gordon does it
connect at all or just no we don't know
I probably just taking the material
doing his own yeah like what are we how
do we make this relevant again the story
of I remember correctly is I'm a
football player and I wind up on this
rocket ship with the reporter and a
scientist yes and we wind up going to
[ __ ] we're Ming the Merciless is
planning to destroy the earth and I have
to stop it from happening for shits and
giggles so you could do that as a
current version yeah and I don't
remember because I never watched the old
serials but I'm pretty sure that he was
not always a football player
they made him a football player what was
he before I don't know but if I remember
it's like normal guy winds up like a cop
or soldier or maybe even astronaut but
quarterback for the New York Jets was
not always part of the Canon no doubt so
you can definitely do that story today
yeah
I'm snatch time here I go up there I
fight the bad guys boom Star Wars yes -
quick director notes Ryan Coogler has
officially signed on for Black Panther 2
which what a shock I know duh I don't
know that it's nice to know it's
official nice to know though officially
be a Black Panther to kind of spoils the
infinity war a little bit but there you
go
yeah we know one hero is coming back
unless they're planning to make one of
those Black Panthers with that Black
Panther and James Gunn is going to
direct Suicide Squad - that's red that
happened while I was away that was big
news that seemed to be the obvious in
the offing being that Joss Whedon left
the Marvel Cinematic Universe
wound up working over at the DC movies
this seemed logical yeah and it's a guy
who can handle that kind of sort of
sideways tone and deal with the humor
and wrestle a bunch of characters to the
ground it seems like a great catch for
Warner Brothers and matched a material
potential material one last thing before
we move on to the next portion of our
show is the end of the news this is the
end of the news and producer named
Raymond chow passed away Raymond chow is
most notable for starting a company
called Golden Harvest back in the 1970s
and producing into the Dragon bringing
Bruce Lee to the big screen to the big
states in a big bad way for the first
time introducing Jackie Chan to western
audiences John Legend of drunken master
project Eiko all of that stuff was him
he produced the teenage Ninja Turtles
feature film back in the 90s and also he
introduced sweetheart
they got to do what's about to come in
China introduced Jet Li to the to the to
the West and for me my heart goes to him
because a Cannonball Run was it was a
Raymond chow production and Megaforce
get out of here deeds not words he's
looking words megaforce was I collected
a bunch of comics in like the 70s and
80s and that was on the back of every
comic every kind deeds not worse he's
not words ace hunter [ __ ] with the
purses combated with hair and I saw that
movie and it was everything I ever
thought a movie could because it was
like dune buggies and BMX bikes and they
all had [ __ ] rocket launchers mounted
on them and there was like pink smoke
out the back at some cool formation
thing because why would you need a
strike force with dune buggies and BMX
bikes and pink smoke flying out the back
don't give a [ __ ] is how lead him wanted
it that way
that he'll meet him have it did he'll
meet him direct Megaforce yep
are you [ __ ] me I never knew that
until just now this nobody stunts like
how leave them stunts and that movie was
just all about [ __ ] flying off the stuff
there's a sequence in that movie that
it's funny my co-writer for the
highwayman the comic book that I did
Adam Freeman is in the corner there's a
scene where they deploy into a
battlefield with a [ __ ] ton of dune
buggies and bikes and they all drop off
the back of a c-130 like cargo plane
which we kind of ripped off for the
highwayman which then The Fast and
Furious movies have been ripped off from
us I'll say it for Fast and the Furious
7 the daisy chain goes all the way back
to Megaforce because that movie was
everything a ten-year-old ever wants out
of a movie at once and the man who
produced that the Raymond chow passed
away at 91 years old 91 90 Walkman to
live a legendary life that includes is
not limited to just includes making
Megaforce yes to make it to 91 man Wow
yes and you know [ __ ] Bruce Lee and
Jackie Chan II gently and massive tail
and legacy indeed so yes he passed away
so hoisted glass when you have if you're
in a bar say I don't know to it to a guy
who seemed to have his finger on a pulse
that nobody else had at the time well
done mr. Chow Chow was Chow really Chow
give it up for Raymond chow that's all
the news as all the news my friend oh my
god we're done with the news ladies and
gentlemen give it up for mark he gave
you the news okay we got a special guest
this week man and we're gonna talk to
her about a massive career that includes
the batman batman the animated series
the amazing warner brothers show that
came out what 92 or whatever has just
been released on this massive box set
you could also watch it on on the DC
Universe app and stuff but this box set
has everything it comes with three
little Funko pops but it has amazing
documentaries about the heart of Batman
and stuff like that every episode ever
done is on this box set so good folks at
Warner Brothers on
Meishan always kind of over-delivering
this is limited-edition I just noticed
man the only 69 thousand copies 69 so
rush out and I can get one as soon as
you can again if you're remotely been a
fan of the show I hear they're gone
almost everywhere so you might have to
go to the aftermarket sounds like you
might go eBay and stuff like that that
all being said man one of the voices in
this universe and every [ __ ] universe
is here tonight to hang out with us and
chitchat and whatnot when I was a kid
there are two famous voices two famous
names in animation providing voices Mel
Blanc was one of them of course who
provided like every animated voice
Warner Brothers June Foray
was the female version where she did
rocky the flying squirrel she did witch
hazel and Warner Brothers she's worked
forever and stuff it's the most
recognizable name in animation in terms
of voicing female characters the
modern-day June Foray who takes it even
further and has voiced your entire life
everything you've ever loved remotely
she's played a part in at this point man
she's here to talk about the work that
she's done and bless us with her
appearance give it up for oh [ __ ] I
could do the list but I'm just gonna
pick that girl ladies and gentlemen Tara
Strong
[Applause]
you guys saw a lot good lord
too much and also Rosie's like my best
impression you want it yeah you've got a
Rosie Perez you lost all our [ __ ]
money Bernie you're so stupid you said I
don't have unity plus infinity
holy she's better than you man no I'm
never gonna called up to the big show
with my [ __ ] Rosie I am I'm so
tempted to just sit here and be like do
this voice do this voice but that's what
you get paid to do so be wrong to like
have you do all the voices I mean it's
kind of why I'm here well really we
should talk to you about how one does
the voices how one got to be as
indispensable as you they don't make
[ __ ] anymore
that's animated unless you're nearby in
some [ __ ] vicinity it seems like
you've got massive long tail in
animation when did you start what was
the first thing I started when I was 13
I grew up in Toronto and my first job
was Hello Kitty and I was the voice of
Hello Kitty and Cree summer was the bad
cat wait a sec the voice of the Hello
Kitty she'd never had a voice before I
know I was the first was that
controversy were people like [ __ ] you
Hello Kitty has no voice well it was
before Twitter so much before Twitter
yeah and I was 13 so food existed I
didn't hear about it but I loved doing
it it was really fun how long it was
like two years maybe and I grew up in a
toy store and my dad was the first
import Hello Kitty into Canada and like
there's pictures of my dad like in the
furry outfit when I'm like five so it's
kind of crazy that I got to we don't
want to talk about your parents I don't
know what they'd get up to and Tdap it
down here we don't go for that furry
Johnson right the what did that what
what did that lead to like does it is
that how it works like hey man I hear
hello kitty can you do something else ah
start developing new people that do one
or two shows and then kind of disappear
but I was really lucky to grow up in
Toronto there's so much production up
there and I did a lot of TV and film and
theater but I also did ton of animation
which kind of paved the way for coming
here the next thing I did that was kind
of big was like beetlejuice I was Claire
and Bertha which is a great show and my
pet monster and Garbage Pail Kids and
yeah a whole bunch of fun stuff in
Toronto before I before I moved here so
and actually took me a few years to get
my feet solid here I was like eviction
notice broke in my apartment like no one
gives a [ __ ] that I'm here and I might
as well go home or get a job somewhere
else cuz I'm not gonna I can't survive
what kept you going so my first job was
Hello Kitty and it was given to me by a
woman named Marsha Goodman who at the
time was head of casting for deke
animation and she called me at my
apartment and she said Tara were redoing
gadgets gadget point Heather will you be
my Heather so she kind of saved me twice
and I'm like and then I was still kind
of coasting and then within the same
year I booked 101 Dalmatians 101
Dalmatians was a Disney show about the
Dalmatians and I played the the
description in the character breakdown
like when you get an audition for an
animated show they give you character
breakdown drawing little story backstory
about the show and they said she's the
only non dog she's a chicken that thinks
she's a dog she's really hyper and crazy
and so on the very first day it was like
a room full of great it was like me and
Pammy Siegel and Iggy and cat Suzy and
Jim Cummings and Frank Welker it was
like this insane room and Tara chair and
off from Toronto is sitting there and
then they play back all your auditions
so that they know so you know what you
did often for an audition you'll do two
three different choices and so I had
this weird idea right before my audition
which is the same way I booked Titans
that maybe every time she says they're a
B or a P she gets stuck on it and starts
and they played it back and it was like
you know I can put up with the grilling
jokes to shut them up or break
references even you asking me why every
time across the web package were like
crazy and it so [ __ ] up watching [ __ ]
come out of your mouth you're like the
girl from The Exorcist man like weird
voices just pop out that's about so book
the part and Pammy was like you're gonna
room for a look great so and you just
blew everyone away which was like we
fell in love on that and then I booked a
little show called batman' so you went
from Disney to Warner Brothers yeah and
it was like that that day booking that
part was like insane cuz that casting
room was full of a list on camera
celebrities ælis voiceover celebrities
and I was like grateful to be in the
room that thought there's not a [ __ ]
chance and I was already doing Kylie for
ghostbusters and like film or this other
like sort of tragic teen and I'm like I
don't know how to make this different
but I hope you know this is me and I
just kind of did or maybe I came after
that came after I lied that was how I
booked Raven for Batman I just did my
own voice and it worked and they like
it's the only show I do that's my own
voice right so what do you do back girl
you're just it's just my voice
it's all [ __ ] acting though man I've
seen behind-the-scenes clips you guys
get like crazy oh yeah you'd be
hard-pressed to find an actor's room
where they're just standing there we're
all moving around within the parameters
of the microphone and do you do it
together as everybody yeah we one of the
great things about Batman is that we all
work together I mean I was in between
Hamill and Conroy like pinching myself
and Arleen Sorkin and all these amazing
actors that you know when you're acting
in a voiceover job you envision what's
happening in your mind and you put
yourself in those scenarios because if
the line is whoa and you're falling off
a cliff or you see a hot guy it's gonna
be two different reads right and so you
really envision these moments and try to
bring them to life and there were
moments of tears and real after and just
to be able to play off the other actors
like you'd get half the creativity if I
didn't get to respond to how Hamill did
something and it was a magical amazing
room they don't always do full cast
record but Batman was really yeah when
was the first
you knew that this was a career and that
you were interested in it like when did
it become like oh [ __ ] I'm gonna do this
for the rest of my life it's funny
because I still have a hard time even
thinking that because I knew when I was
like three four years old that I want to
be singer dancer actress but I didn't
know is it gonna be voiceover and people
say oh you're a voice actor sometimes I
go what because it's like I don't really
think of myself as a voice actress I
think of myself as an actress that gets
to play in this amazing world which is
an amazing world and I'm super grateful
for it but I I it took me a while to
realize oh I'm pretty big in that world
I mean maybe the internet or Comic Cons
when suddenly I you know couldn't walk
from A to B unless I was dressed as
Harley which is really fun did you see
that have you done that oh yeah so you
don't follow me on Twitter so you miss
all the fun don't criticize she's one of
the audience I was on your side I will
totally follow you it's like she called
you out for a dance fine bodied heaven
okay so I cosplayed Harley and I totally
surprised my fans normally when I'm
walking from my hotel to the con I get
stopped a lot but as Harley I didn't
really because everybody's Harley except
that people stop makes it was a really
good costume I had it made and one guys
like can I take your picture Harley's my
favorite and there's been like 13 today
and I went up I don't know I've seen a
lot of good ones I couldn't wait for a
guy to go home and like make his iPhone
a little bigger and check it out
wait I'm gonna I'm stuck on you had a
costume made yeah did you ever have a
Batgirl costume made see if you followed
me did you really have a Batgirl costume
and you were [ __ ] made that's a
beautiful I've never even had a Silent
Bob costume made that's so cute man
that's cool it was pretty hot what else
have you wait do you always make
costumes with the characters you play or
just um typically because it's fun
did you ever do didn't you do the fairly
oddparents where are you Tim Utah
I've never done it in a returner timmy
turner no I think that I mean it'd be
fun
no I've done Harley I've done injustice
Harley and injustice to Harley injustice
is the trampy one the one with the skirt
well they're all pretty tramping not the
og harley is now she's nobody she's a
classy broad very classy
Batgirl I've done a she from Samurai
Jack yeah that was pretty hot well you
have like 500 IMD credits like how much
closet do you have we've just got this
just in the actual photo look at you
reporter yeah see I told you is hot well
done I wasn't doubting take us into the
world of Batman how many years I think
at this point have you been playing
Batgirl you've done all the back girls
right Oh sometimes casting makes
mistakes but for those of us that watch
the animated stuff right like whenever I
mean you know no disrespect to anybody
and I loved Peter Weller's Dark Knight
in the Dark Knight Returns but whenever
it's not Kevin Conroy I'm like why are
they [ __ ] around again man I don't
know what to play Batman but like
whenever I hear even if I read comics I
hear Kevin Conroy voice in my head when
I read Batgirl I hear your voice in my
head because you've defined the [ __ ]
character now for the fans watching them
switch the voice it's kind of it could
be irritating what is it like when
you've played the character forever and
then suddenly they're like oh this week
it's gonna be somebody else because
they've their kid likes the show or
something like that I mean you think
you're irritated like it's so
frustrating and any actor that says
they're not hurt by it is completely
full of [ __ ] like they're just lying and
voice actors are pretty much hosed they
won't say no to anything like I've never
heard a voice actor go yeah I don't
really want to redo Batgirl or redo a
different part and it's never ever
money voiceover unless you're on The
Simpsons you started scale every time
which is like something yeah and then as
the show gets more successful you get
little bumps like scale and a half scale
3/4 or whatever it is so it's never ever
about money it's always like some
producer wants to make a creative choice
and try something new or they think they
need some big on-camera celebrity and
when you create a character at least for
me like they live up in my brain and
basically a crazy person
and they come down to play when it's
their turn and when I see someone else
playing it I get really annoyed mm-hm
and I've become Matt with Harley which
is funny because I wasn't the first
Harley and I'm sorry I love her so much
but now I get pissed off I go Harley
when someone else's Harley just that's
sweet and hypocritical at the same time
and by the way you never get angry at
the other actors because it's not like
the other actors are going hey I could
do Tara's voice for half the price you
know doing that a long time knocking on
doors going you know terror I do her
voice half the price man I only watched
that once and the guy never worked again
it was a scooby-doo and he came in and
he said to Welker who by the way is like
the most beloved cherished soul in the
universe and still sounds like Fred even
though I don't even write Welker did the
voice of Fred and as done voices like
more voices than he's the Mikey and
Raiders maybe more than me what yeah
[ __ ] little like the monkey with the
dates that monkey did the voice of yeah
was anyone tell the monkey look he got
the David Prowse monkey for half the
price anywho there was a session and
this kid came in from out of state and
said I can copy all the way I don't know
how he got the part but he copied
everything Frank does in the booth and
said aren't you getting too old for this
everyone was like wait what because
typically voice voiceover actors are
like the nicest people in the world's
not about what you look like and I'm
amazed every day by what my cohorts can
do so
didn't work again I mean it was just
shitty was there like a voice fight we
gonna throw down in the booth he's like
I summon the power of Yogi Bear I throw
at you Grape Ape I go old school what is
your favorite memory from organ I'm
Batman the Animated Series being in the
room all those times and you got to
figure you were in the room at least how
many episodes have they done of this
show Gary okay episodes man Gary moon Oh
give it up for him ladies the man
responsible 109 and Batgirl probably in
at least 30% 40% of them and stuff by
the end when it became like a Batman
family was everybody and stuff so that's
a lot of times in the room with all
those legends of which you were one of
them as well
we can throw us something throw us a
bone what was your it doesn't have to be
the top number one favorite memory but
was one of your favorite memories of
being there recording the show I really
like have so many memories of really
just being happy really just being in
the booth with Conroy and Hamill like it
was just it really felt like I could die
tomorrow like this is amazing and
literally every time I went in was like
that there was never a bad day but
probably my favorite episode was girls
night out
oh it's such a [ __ ] great episode and
it was just so fun to be like this
kick-ass superhero chick and have a
partner and you know we're going out and
kicking ass and then we're like in our
robes talking about boys or whatever
like it was just it's it really
humanized superhero chicks and I had so
much fun that day it was probably one of
my favorite days have you ever had to
voice against yourself like play
multiple roles in a song that I'm really
every day so on on Batman would you do
more than Batgirl like on some animation
there like we'd like to get three voices
out of it yeah they they typically like
to because when you get a scale fee it's
up to three characters so they're gonna
pick someone that's more versatile like
I often meet people I really want to do
voice over and like I'm so sorry
it's not about sounding like a crazy
person like maybe you'll get one but it
doesn't sustain a very long career you
the people that are that work a lot of
very versatile so
I think on Batman there was a few
incidental characters on that run but
like today I play Batgirl ivy Harley and
Raven in the same episode of like a DC
girls or whatever it is not DC girls I'm
not Batgirl in DC girls but yeah and I'm
doing myself arguing with myself see you
and you're doing all the voices it's
really great therapy how does like how
does that deep I mean I don't mean to
get political but you're Canadian taking
jabs man like doing all those voices
that's a lot of boys that how does it
wind up just being one person they're
like wow you do IV as well well you did
this one as well well just do all the
girls like do you have that many
different girl voices to be able to do
yes what's what's Ivy's voice well on
the last the DC superheroes she was
really sweet for some reason they just
wanted her to be like a really nice kind
of I love DC super girl I mean that
sounds dirtier than I meant it but
that's just the concept is very cool the
idea of them being kids in high school
is adorable yeah and I've played her
sexy too and a lot of time the show
dictates you know how dark it's gonna be
I mean there was that amazing short what
was that called Gary Gary Gary that
short with Bruce where Harley was like
darker than Joker and it took place like
in Chicago or something dude I'm talking
about you don't we just sold you as the
cure to cancer man Jesus anyway that was
like darker than any other Harley ever
she was completely a maniac and you know
then on DC girls she's she's like hey
one day life's back back you know you
know like she's a lot lighter and then
depending on what the mood of the show
is dictates how you're gonna do the
voice do you was what was the kill did
you do background The Killing Joke yes
so you did Batgirl when she was young
and innocent and then you did back her
when she got down with Batman was that
was that as weird for you as it was for
the rest of us
like I remember watching that being like
oh no that's like her uncle yeah
somebody better tell James Gordon by the
way I'm with you Kevin is Batman
for the record Kevin Conroy well I find
like that that will forever be Batman's
voice because of this show because I'm
in the animated series he is Batman and
Hamill is the Joker and I was friends
with other people that play them but
there is no replacing them and I miss
them when they're not on it and for me
personally comic-book wise like I
gravitate towards the dark stuff so even
though it's been done funnier like this
is that you can't top this and it by the
way that whenever they call it is
amazing this new blu-ray like you
thought it looked amazing before it's
like it's mind-blowing to see the colors
and everything mind you this was an
animation process I'm sure I'm not
telling anybody in this room anything
new but they animated using black
backgrounds which was revolutionary
because there's mostly white backgrounds
that you're drawn and stuff we're clear
acetate and they put on black
backgrounds which gave the show this
very authentic and artistic look right
and it holds up that film noir it's so
cool so when I got the Killing Joke
script first of all any time I open a
script and I see Batgirl and to me I'm
stoked
anyway like I'll give a [ __ ] was bad I'm
the air man right and having read The
Killing Joke it's too short for a
feature and so I loved that they gave
background something to do became like
the first half of the Batgirl story and
then like the Twitter hey guys it's not
her dad we were like that would have
been weird that's where we are in
America that's the line I don't know I
loved it so much and it was a creative
choice I didn't think it was gratuitous
I didn't think it was good too dizzy
though I wasn't offended by it now on
some level I was like oh that's
interesting but on the other level of
like well they used to hang out when she
was really young
but but you don't like as the performer
you don't get a [ __ ] say you could
never be like hey man I'm gonna put my
foot down back girl would never do this
to like max you're like hold on I'll do
it for Half Price
that's not entirely true the actors get
some say in certain lines like an entire
story arc would be hard to argue with
but when it comes to lines they they
listen here and there like years and
years ago I was doing a Rugrats episode
and if you remember but when the Rugrats
like went into their imaginary world you
guys all got to see that and so they
were in a car dealership and while
they're waiting for their dad to pick a
car all the babies were in a van and
suddenly they pretended they were
underwater in a submarine and they were
looking at all the fish around them and
there was like a heavyset woman that
came by in my line or someone else's
lines look at the whale and I'm a child
of a very heavy woman she was teased her
entire life I would hold her hand while
she cried and tell her how beautiful she
was and I saw how horrible that bullying
was and I said hey guys why don't we
make in a muscle man and not a heavyset
woman and they said done they didn't
even think about it so [ __ ] being
Batgirl real hero maybe like crack a
window for these kids playing in this
car that was before those health codes
you get away with stuff
what is [ __ ] man like roll out the
resume the fact that he's just through
[ __ ] Rugrats I was like Jesus that to
go through not everything but throw out
throw out like just impress us throw out
a bunch of names
all right well fairly oddparents of
course
Teen Titans Raven on Teen Titans right
yeah yes the weight in the Teen Titans
go to the movies as well yeah did you
see it yeah of course money what was the
yes very legit funny like they make a
lot of great DC Universe jokes too and
funny but what [ __ ] man were you like
blown away when they were like we're
doing this is movie or is it a blown
away
I'm so happy I've seen it three times
and I could see it more I've been in
other movies and oh my god I can't I
just love it so much
so funny all right so keep going
Twilight Sparkle my little pony
that's right man I forgot my god the
bronies must love you do you have a
costume I surprised the fans at a con
and came out as Twilight as a person yes
I've done that I just took over for the
new Rocky and Bullwinkle did you know
that I am a huge rocket BOGO fan who are
you voicing hokey smokes Kevin you don't
know that's your Rocky that's my Rocky
that's fantastic did you have to study
it for a long time and actually the
first auditions were I didn't book it
the first time and when I went back for
the callbacks they said we don't want it
to be a voice match we want it to be a
little bit older a little bit wiser and
I thought I liked also the most guy
sounds exactly like moose so I thought
it was kind of an odd choice but I did
what they asked and then at the next
callback they did a chemistry read so I
was with Bullwinkle and it was like
nerve-racking cuz it's one of those
parts that's like wow you got to play
Rocky it's pretty exciting she really
really wanted it yeah and it felt good
if it still didn't feel like in the
pocket for me and then sorry honey and
then she's trying to get you to stand
right down the Battle of the camp yeah
when she passed I swear to god it's
almost like she jumped in and like this
is how it's done and it became more
classic Rocky and we were already at
like Episode four or five and I begged
the the director let me go back and rock
if I like all of it because it just felt
like in the pocket you know like it had
to be Rocky and this this we're on
season two that's coming out soon is so
funny
it's produced by DreamWorks and it's on
Amazon and it's really really good the
animation is good the jokes are good
Bullwinkle but all the voices are like
bang on it's really really good
who's uh
she Jun did both rocky and Natasha right
so because I wasn't originally cast I
didn't play her but it was Rachel of
Butera and she does an amazing job and
Brad Norman is Bullwinkle and piata
having a brain fart this isn't gonna be
recorded or anything right anyway look
up the cast they're really great I
didn't know all right keep going [ __ ]
man that's cool I didn't know that I
didn't number one I didn't know that the
newborn one comes out already
yeah yeah I know you should see it it's
really funny all right what else
I'm Benton Wow
chowder I was truffles and chowder do
you guys remember that show you don't
remember her she was no pianist may I
just get delighted I could watch you
speaking voices all day long man it's
fun I think it's the Christian in me I'm
like it's like you got family and stuff
like that yes I have two boys and do
they know about yeah they really love me
I'm Rick and Morty I play tinkles on
Rick and hoarding at the other part the
song did you sing the song yeah do you
remember the words do you know I'm not
as you to perform it that was more of a
question i would if i remembered it I
can't remember it I know you're a born
performer you just [ __ ] dive into and
chill you're like the least fair bring
your mom to school day person I know
like what's your mom do well you know
she's a lawyer she's a doctor that's all
great what's your mom do everything you
love
she's the voice of your childhood
[ __ ] hit it mom I hear that
every con thank you for my childhood
you're the worst of my childhood and I
have done that at school and probably
ruined it for their parents yeah my kids
when they were little they used to do
more like we'd be like in line somewhere
at Target and my son go
you know she's bubbles right from
Powerpuff Girls and they'd be like do it
do it do it do it we have to stop
otherwise I'm gonna burst with joy
whatever that really [ __ ] happens
give it up for the insanely [ __ ]
talented but Tara's gonna come back here
and join us behind the bar for Q&A we're
gonna do QA a little differently this
week instead of asking old me and Mark
stuff you get to ask Tara stuff
obviously she's got a great story career
and she knows a bunch of stuff before
while she's walking up here I just
wanted to point out for those who are
not sharp-eyed I am wearing a fat man
beyond pin on my lapel features me and
marked in the logo did you just notice
oh I got one jump in the middle here you
can find him at Jay and Silent Bob calm
I think they just went on sale man all
right so this awesome box set is a
potential for somebody to walk home with
tonight this is a gift
well it's insanely limited as I said
before 69,000 Gary was a real sweetheart
and scored one for us here to give out
tonight in order to win
this we were talking before the show
began like what is the [ __ ] bar for
this you can't just ask a question and
stuff it has to be something huge did
you you probably didn't think of any bar
I I feel like it's a a question that's
predominately for Tara yes like an
entire Jam
yes and I think maybe we'll have three
people ask questions and Tara will
choose which of those three is the best
question oh that's shitty you can't do
that to Tara where she's like this one
yeah cuz then she loses to fans who are
like [ __ ] that voice chick and we don't
want that we can give consolation prizes
for those three tickets I feel like we
should do this first was a Solomon that
[ __ ]
cut the box in half that's right let's
solemn in this [ __ ] take it right out of
the Old Testament why not what if first
best question wins like here's the thing
whoever gets to go first if your
question is amazing you win the box set
then it has to be in order to be an
amazing question you have to produce an
amazing response that's being like big
old juicy response can't be like a
simple yes-or-no has to be a real
thought-provoking kind of like oh [ __ ]
that's that's [ __ ] insane that
question wins the box set if you're the
first one and you don't ask a question
that good we have secondary prize which
is normally our first prize man deacon
and the good folks of 4dx dropped off
tickets for us to give away and stuff
and that's no booby prize for TX movie
is a [ __ ] incredible experience watch
you can go see the Grinch in 4dx
calendar you're in the Grinch as well
yeah you were directed by [ __ ] Scott
Scott Mosier yeah [ __ ] a man
God are you never what aren't you in for
Christ in sins have you ever
having it's also dinner right there I
did a Futurama did you see me I danced
on bender no I didn't know that but I
don't you put me on the [ __ ] spot
tonight and [ __ ] but is that a dream to
be on The Simpsons I mean it'd be fun
because of the money or because it was a
good pool well I wouldn't get paid like
they do those those are like they've
been on the show for however many years
and yes people don't get that right
that'd be fun yeah fun to do Futurama
because I had a full table read and it's
like all my friends are there and yeah
it was just funny and fun all right
don't make this really sad for whoever
doesn't win how well hey it looks
amazing but B there's also like special
interviews behind the scenes from like
everyone do you make it worse for
there's a lot of people walking away
without this tonight but they go find it
on the internet right go find one Gary
what's this what's the status of the box
set was it sold out everywhere
or it's gonna be selling out fairly
quickly get your hands on it when you
can folks okay go do you look a
blockbuster so yes go to your local
Blockbuster I saw it recently in a
commercial for Captain Marvel let's
let's start the questions Ben J seed you
pick some folks bang oh [ __ ] you didn't
discuss feeling it all right man you're
gonna be first and you've got a golden
chance to win this box that which I bet
you we can get Tara to sign would you
sign it [ __ ] that girl will you sign
this box set well the question has to be
amazing and if you get it if the
question is amazing right off the bat
you get it we all [ __ ] go home and
[ __ ]
but let's get your the question is it's
okay you steel wins and 40x tickets
maybe if the question is terrible like
will be like sit the [ __ ] down
so there's tears here there's a bunch of
things that could happen man what's your
name my name is Oscar Oscar everyone
give it up for Oscar he's gonna do it
all right Oscar take your shot first off
I didn't know this was gonna happen so
awesome if I don't that's fine with me I
just have a question or two questions
that I've been wanting to ask you guys
for some time now I fear haven't been
able to have a platform to do that fair
enough sounds like it's not gonna be for
the box that but for the 4dx tickets may
be very alright so my first question is
I'm with Bohemian Rhapsody that just
came out Elton John's movie that's
coming out soon and then the other
biopics that have come out before like
Selena and NWA and all these other
movies I always wondered what musical
artists would you guys like to see a
biopic of or of a band if you have and
who would you cast as the lead I picked
two Run DMC they have a fantastic origin
story and it's a some of its mired in
the comic book culture as well and the
Talking Heads a couple kids from RISD
wound up being one of the most popular
bands on the planet
I think there's and also their story is
fraught and complicated and they all
kind of fray and fall apart at the end
so there's drama there for a good movie
Run DMC is just about you know [ __ ]
sock on it rise watch the beginning
watching hip hop be born with the unto
the Kings from Queens so those would be
my two choices you I was thinking the
whole time like you should direct them
particularly not the Run DMC one but
I'll be the first in line to pay for it
and stuff that'd be good
you haven't had a hendrix movie right we
have not okay okay I'd like to see that
it would be awesome yeah I'm really
excited for the
the cream was weaned of the Queen I was
like they're making a cream bio bit
hairless Lipton sweet Wow
yes the Queen one Mike Mark was talking
about it earlier yeah I did
don't get him started man Oh mark what
is it uh kiss ya [ __ ] I'm not even a
huge kiss fan [ __ ] that would be an
amazing movie man make up alone and [ __ ]
the decision to put on the makeup which
I was always thought was kind of
brilliant I don't know if they realized
it when they did it but it made them
[ __ ] ageless because you could be an
80 year old put on that makeup and
people see like the cat the story saying
that they want to sound good - yeah I
mean kiss I think Beastie Boys would be
interesting
yeah I'd see that and [ __ ] Prince
give me a person and then my second
question that I have also yeah it's
usually one but you squeeze another one
is you got the mic oh it's just um
I've been trying to broaden my horizons
when it comes to movies as I'm not as
well-versed as most people none of us
are none of us are as well-versed as we
think I was wondering if you guys had
top three female leading movies for
example with me I really enjoy Sybil Wow
I was forced to watch it at school and
psychology class and I loved it since it
was the school assignment it was a
school of salmon with multiple
personality disorder study and all that
stuff my second movie was a Joy Luck
Club also another school assignment that
I left and in my most recent take is
Wonder Woman top three for me I was
wondering what it would be for you guys
as well you start here the lady
speak of an answer I could give you one
right off the bat I can give you three
but I give you the first one aliens for
sure yes but I shouldn't I should be
able to dig deeper than that so I'll
pass off to other people I think of two
more good I mean you have to think about
that really what was really great well
the hard thing is three and then all of
a sudden you're faced with like oh my
god like [ __ ] I can't believe I
rested on aliens but the good news is
that we all kind of agree aliens is a
very strong female lead movie okay I'll
give you three go the professional yeah
good pole um [ __ ] I have the other two
hold on I could T off on that one okay
go Gloria John Cassavetes nice okay an
amazing movie I've ever seen that I have
not no oh it's [ __ ] awesome it's
about a lady who is mob adjacent or she
used to have a boyfriend in the mob she
lives in an apartment building it
borrows heavily though the professional
borrowed heavily from it
the gangsters come in to kill this
family that she's right next door to and
she don't want to get involved in the
kid went off to get some milk when a
little boy in the apartment and as his
family's getting slaughtered he comes
home and he [ __ ] knows it and he goes
to her apartment instead he rings the
bell and she looks out the people and
she don't want to [ __ ] open the door
and [ __ ] and he's standing there knowing
that soon they're gonna come out of the
hallway find him there and [ __ ] take
him inside and kill him and [ __ ] and she
doesn't want to answer the door general
an amazing performance and finally opens
the door and pulls them in and the
adventure begins
fantastic [ __ ] movie and they bought a
bunch for the professional Moria that's
what it's called monster was Shirley's
throne yeah
directed by patty Jenkins who would then
go on to do Wonder Woman and sounds
little lambs Silence of the Lambs what a
great Paul yes that is one what you you
could do it in character do it in
character voice it'll be fun whatever
like where there's one chick leader
there's no it could be your baby boys
can win the movie but the lead story
should be a girl story
Oh what about Sophie's Choice [ __ ] you
yeah it's also the saddest sorry
suddenly we're all sitting around going
what would I do towards one which is a V
swing thank you I thought that was a
great III enjoy as well boy I'm really
purple disappoint ya what a great
[ __ ] ball thank you that's a great
redeem myself from witches Eastwick it's
weird I guess I'm you know I'm fairly
male centric right like I'm a guy when I
go to the movies I'm always kind of like
oh it's a guy's story and I can identify
with that what's your favorite movie
ever of all time yeah either jaws JFK do
the right thing Last Temptation of
Christ or you know I do like clerks an
awful lot Jaws JFK do the right thing
Star Wars man for all seasons and The
Last Temptation of Christ man for all
seasons is a very heavily metal driven
cast I guess all those movies are
heavily male driven well I feel like I
should watch more female driven movies
but I don't know I mean I remember like
that's when we wants to go see Wonder
Woman my wife was crying in the first
few moments of the movie when they like
jumping off the cliff and firing arrows
and [ __ ] and I was watching movie like
this is [ __ ] metal I saw it in the
trailer but this is [ __ ] metal and
[ __ ] she didn't watch trailers so she's
jukin bawling-crying I was like what's
the matter what happened she's like I've
waited my whole life to see something
like this she's like you see it every
[ __ ] week she's gone this is
something I never get to see look at
this women kick an ass and [ __ ] so I
yeah I guess I tend to be fairly male
centric in my viewing which makes sense
because I'm a guy but I feel bad that I
could only really come up with one right
off the top of my head and girl fight
you should see the descent you should
see
I'm just showing off man like I'm
flipping out my big lady dick right now
Gone with the Wind you could see gone
with the wind as well I would erode its
long
fury road excellent Paul's Terminator
[ __ ] terminator too particularly well
done Cujo good point man
that is a mom driven story that dog is a
[ __ ] all right is that enough [ __ ] you
give it up for I'm giving some tickets
he wins tickets take some tickets all
right JC give us another one here we go
you're playing for the box set right now
potentially potential to win the box
that what's your name mark everyone give
it up a mark
how do you spell it I'm gonna try for
the box how do you spell it ma RK the
right way nobody's perfect and by the
way next time you're in Boston they are
building a veggie girl in Cambridge are
they fine yeah amen man you're doing one
in Times Square I heard in New York and
I heard there was one coming it's coming
good all right you know on the inside
with veggie grill do they like slip you
[ __ ] at this point I pay attention
I'm very supportive all right time
square what movie or television show
that you're a fan of that's never been
animated would you like to see made
animated and what character would you
voice holy [ __ ] man just sign it right
now we might as well that was a loaded
gun we gotta unpack it say it again we
would slow cuz I'm stoned what
television show or movie whatever show
or move let me translate what even
though she understands what television
show or movie that's never been animated
and it's never been animated before
would you like to see animated would you
like would you tera like to see animated
and what character in it would you voice
and what character in it would you voice
I can't imagine a better [ __ ]
question happening tonight for our guest
give it up for him that's a great
[ __ ] question
[Applause]
it's up to you ma'am welcome I have to
think about that really hard like
because when you go from a live-action
to animate it you have to give it a
reason like why is it going animated
like maybe if they had you know a raven
movie it would be like so epic with her
powers like that would be cool feed her
like a raven movie starring Tara Strong
it'd be pretty cool are you pitching
right now yeah are you gonna direct it
he's neither of the Warner Brothers if I
chose I'd like to see alias Jennifer
Gardner's alias turned into an animated
show that's your pick
that was what I'd like to see it's a
[ __ ] what a great poem an alias
animated yeah so it's kind of like an
older so that sci-fi feel to it the
mystery of all that craziness going on I
think it would translate great that's a
great poem man you like chick flicks you
doing Sophie's Choice interrogate voice
the mom and the kids man and it's a
musical because of course it's gonna be
musical man will get Lynn to write the
songs it'll be which one should I choose
no why did I have to no that was not my
real answer but now I really want to see
you there man and Meryl Streep could
voice it still no offense okay I'm
trying to think if I even have one it's
TV show it's a movie but it's never been
animated before jaws oh my god set the
shark boys all right I'm gonna pull my
answer I'm gonna change it right away
let me see what if I like that I mean
buckaroo banzai and [ __ ] watch a
animated series of oh would that be hi
Game of Thrones yeah be cool okay be
tough to top the original though right
we've seen the [ __ ] in real life I think
we've stalled all weekend do you have a
response because if he stumps you he
wins two box sets we only have one
there's only really if I was gonna
answer honestly I'd really have to think
about it and make it smart I'm gonna say
something dumb like Sophie's Choice I'm
glad she's on to you now this is like
it's like a genie in the bottle kind of
you say that because there's an old old
movie called The Thief of Bagdad did you
ever see that yeah it'd be kind of cool
animated yeah but they've done that a
few they did receive about Ali Baba and
the Forty Thieves Bugs Bunny dude well
but not that story Oh Aladdin but you
did say that and it popped in my head
thank you thinking what old movies cuz
maybe an old movie would be cool what
was your favorite movie as a kid I loved
well my favorite movie of all time is
defending your life I loved that movie
too but I don't know how animated Albert
bridge make a bunch of animated dick
well I've seen dude I've seen Finding
Nemo animated
Albert Brooks is just fine boy good
point man it works Jerry makes a lot of
money my bad
I Love Lucy animated cute Wow would it
be in color that would throw off the
dynamic right like we were well we've
only ever seen the show on black and
white you know I'm gonna be driving home
ago oh my god I got in that's gonna be
know when I'm driving home Oh
Driving Miss Daisy the cartoon [ __ ] yes
[Music]
they animated Gilligan's Island once
they did yeah I think kids I mean I
don't know if the parent you broke her
we need some answers yeah the one that
you really want to hear from is
I'm gonna let you know like tomorrow
give me your never enough give me her
number
suddenly Harley Quinn calls you my
roommate would go insane cuz he was just
at the Rhode Island comic on Sunday and
met Kevin Conroy oh yeah he was me he's
on his face where you put a picture you
were there as well uh-huh oh wow I was
supposed to be but I'm working out here
this week to be you man mm-hmm sucks to
be you what are you what are you doing
out here for a week what kind of job
works for a week I have an Amazon store
so I buy things I sell things so I
travel you can't [ __ ] bury the lede
like that we're like I have an Amazon
store anyway about the cartoons I'm
self-employed how's that that's cool
that's cool so what i trap out here you
buy some [ __ ] and then you sell em I
sell it yeah are you gonna sell that no
no my roommates gonna go insane when he
sees that come into the house and I'm
gonna tease the hell out of them with it
are you a spy because that sounds like
some cover [ __ ]
do I look like I'm ashamed like a slug
that's the best disguise
what kind of [ __ ] are you looking for
because I got a big garage I do mostly
video games and a lot of other stuff
like that boys all right
I'm Stalin do you think of anything come
on man we're working here it's really
all been done everything's been animated
like you could say splash but look at
the Little Mermaid it's done
Degrassi Degrassi Degrassi would be a
great car - it's probably like film or
recess or something probably exists
already bird lacasa phone - think about
it
I killed it the road warrior I've ruined
the show what yeah I was in the
Animatrix who are you a bunch of people
like that crazy nurse chick you were
many voices yeah presumed innocent
I love the presumed innocent oh yes yes
every we and the cartoon happens after
the movie so it's like watching them
deal with the fact that Bonnie Bedelia
knows that he murdered or she know he
knows that Bonnie Bedelia murder and
[ __ ] like that
and he's always like passed the butter
she's like what the [ __ ] did you say
it's like nothing nothing it's all good
it's all good
did you ever see presumed innocent if
you did that's very she's like a lawyer
that's awesome cute okay I go now
go and I thought you're giving us such a
good politics break for me I know right
you're not thinking about the election
opponent well don't even bring it up
think about think about the year that
Lex Luthor won the presidency Comics
will keep it on the level of comics Tom
Legally Blonde counts and you could be
believed what was her name Ellie yeah
Elmo would write so you would be the
write the lead we finally got an answer
she answered give it up for tired but
more importantly man you ask the
question and it was a great question and
it almost stumped her and I will it came
through I think you want to I don't want
to wreck it ooh JC with the [ __ ]
knife yeah metal you aren't [ __ ] man
that was like butterfly staus here we go
man signed by a member of the cast key
member of the Batman animated series
cast I'm assuming you don't want it
personalized cuz Amazon doesn't like no
no you can you can personalize it to
whom me I'm gonna give it to my roommate
so give me get to Chris CHR is not that
sweet been gonna have some fun if he
gets it at the end of the day is good if
all the price he has to pay is Mark
teases of all that's not bad there it is
man he won the box that give it up for
him ladies and gentlemen mark excellent
question sir happy hunting
we have two tats the tickets left we got
some more stuff two more questions we
get out of here folks God who wants to
ask a question hey Kevin how are you I'm
good
first want to say congratulations I'm
looking amazing and doing a healthy
recovery
thank you trying to stay above ground
big time thank myself so I guess good
hey well done man you know secondly Run
Lola Run excellent [ __ ] call Run Lola
Run he's gone where's the guy that
wanted to see all the girl he ran he he
went to watch [ __ ] all the movies
right away
welcome for a prize or anything I
actually worked on I know that voice
documentary on voice actors so I kind of
an advantage oh right I just wanted to
ask Tara to talk about working with
directors like Andrea and all that in
the process between working as a voice
actress and working with voice directors
and what that all entails beautiful man
really good question because it's a huge
frustration right now in the voice-over
industry because Andrea retired yeah I
think that recently recently she was
having health issues with her eyes and
it was devastating because doing Batman
with her was amazing it was run like a
radio play like we'd have a table read
and she's an actor's director she went
to college and took acting and directing
and she knows how to speak to actors and
it's like this really crappy trend where
they hire anyone to be a voice director
and they're like can you make that line
more squiggly and I'm like that's not my
language I don't know what that means
and it's very frustrating as the
performer to like have what's organic be
stunted by someone that doesn't know
what they're doing and that is more
common than not today so I give away ten
of them for one Andre I mean she was
amazing with that said there's a lot of
really really great ones that I love to
work with and it makes a difference when
they're good and they know how to deal
with actors I mean some voice directors
like make you feel like oh I guess I
don't know what the hell I'm doing like
because they don't know what to say and
it really just recently I was doing a
show and there was so much line reading
which you know basically they'll say to
you can you do it like this let's get
out of here like well my character
wouldn't say it like that I'm sure you
heard that yeah yeah the great one if
the actor really can't hear it you're
like just give it to me like they want
you to go let's get out of here but when
a voice director is line reading the
actors the entire time you kind of feel
like what am I here for I'm just here to
copy you and then as a creative it gets
frustrating if you don't give a [ __ ]
about the project then it wouldn't
affect you but I get like I get upset
I'm like why am I here if you want me to
just copy you I don't know but a good
voice director makes all the difference
in the world
and it should be fun even if it's a
serious show it's a cartoon so if you
have someone that makes you feel good
about your performance and you're
playing off the other actors and you're
having a good time that translates on
the show nice thank you
question great answer give it up for him
ladies and gentlemen take some tickets
my friend you're gonna have tickets
anyway yeah go see you do yours there we
go
one last question then we all get to go
home ladies and gentlemen and everyone
can unfortunately and then we have to
look at the election results I know you
don't have to you got your you live in
la-la land and you can make fun voices
you're fine my god it must be amazing to
be around you all the time you could
literally just change voices I do it all
the time do you really yeah I always
change voices it's nuts
here we go give it up for Keith
everybody guys that pinkies got some
gifts for you there and Tara oh my god
thank you what are these are these
magnets oh my god thank you yes I said
don't even bring that one up hope you
enjoyed those camping I love them and
Tara what inspired you to be a voice
actor and are there any roles
classically animated voice roles or
voice roles that you would love to play
and what would you be your audition tape
for that role well I get inspired when I
see a drawing or I hear like a really
good backstory and a lot of times I'll
give you like drawings of you in there
and what they live in like for my little
pony I had worked with Lawren on
Powerpuff Girls so we knew each other
very well and she came to my house and
she said would you mind laying down like
a demo to pitch the show and she had
like ten drawings of Equestria that were
like insane art like beautiful art of
course I said yes
so you get inspired by creatives on the
other end of the scenes of what's going
on and that also changes what you're
doing and then within that you have to
be ready to be there play-doh because
they might go oh now we want her a
little bit older a little bit younger a
little chubbier maybe she's no tease
maybe she's ringlets maybe now she's a
boy what can I jump in yeah chubbier
yeah you know give her a little more
girth you might want to do all right so
hold on do a six-year-old boy who's thin
same boy too much sugar oh my god it is
[ __ ] different that's not that's
crazy so they could be like giving me a
fatter and you could do that [ __ ]
crazy I know you went back to your
answers anything any past that paycheck
would have been nice so it's more about
well number one it's exposure - right
like everyone knows that show world over
although they don't the world over they
don't like they don't do their voices
like somebody else does the voices yes
sometimes sometimes I'll travel
somewhere and I'll hear like someone
else doing my thing and it makes me
laugh a lot like if you go to Mexico
let's say and you hear yourself in
Spanish it's a weird I'm sure you've had
this and it's not you it's somebody else
right you will be approached one day by
an actress that says I'm you in
Guatemala oh I over voice you like the
Italian chicks voice you oh that's kind
of hot like you know you hear different
people I play you in Japan or whatever
is that's fun but sometimes they they
play them or they can watch them online
what and here you do yeah and here the
original voices have do they try to
match your yeah really I mean cuz they
could just go off the church cuz its
animation but they're like I'm gonna
honor what's there yeah Wow do you have
a lot of international Silent Bob's well
Silent Bob's got one line per movie so I
remember the first time somebody showed
me like the VHS cassette of clerks in
Mexico I was laughing about Jays voice
because I was like oh my god that's what
Jay sounds like that's nuts and I forgot
that I had a line and then Jay was like
let me hear your [ __ ] voice and I was
like oh [ __ ] I have a line too and so we
fast forwarded to it and they got
somebody who is I think the line Ryu was
do it fatter because the guy was like
way there's a million foreign live and
women in the world but obviously in
Spanish I can't do it but yeah it's not
seeing somebody else voice yeah it was
kind of crazy
great question give it up for Keith he
want some tickets can you take these
tickets don't forget these very
important 4dx theater man that's it we
had a tickets I mean some we had a news
we are indeed that means we had a guest
we had a box sets we had a show ladies
and gentlemen tonight right before I
came to the show I was telling Tara
backstage my kid works for DC daily on
the DC Universe and so we went out to
veggie grill today and she goes you
you're never gonna believe who I'm
interviewing tomorrow
I said who she goes Tara Strong and I
was like oh you're interviewing her
tomorrow I'm interviewing her tonight so
so when Tara leaves here she goes to
sleep gets up and then meets another
Smith who's probably gonna ask her the
same exact [ __ ] questions go easy on
her she's looking forward to really like
at your house yeah and she's so cute I
fell over on insta and she's holy jeez
no we're gonna eat I'm sure you will
give it up for our guest ladies and
gentlemen the great tower strong and
that's all the show we got for you have
you had a good time ladies and gentlemen
come on back and see us again when we do
this we're doing it next week we're
doing it next Tuesday tickets on sale
right now man come on back see the show
next week and there is no show without
the guys standing next to the lady who's
standing next to me give it up for mr.
mark Bernard and ladies and gentlemen
and that is fat man on Batman this week
no it's family and beyond this oh my god
oh I forgot I'm still stuck in the past
that is fat man beyond for this week
ladies gentlemen I'm Kevin Smith I'm
Mark Barnard tune in next time same fad
time same fat channel SModcast calm or
YouTube that comes Kevin Smith go beyond
folks thanks for being arrogant I
[Applause]